For the past three years, it felt like
Google was behind Open AI in AI. It felt
like ChateBT was just taking over the
world, whereas Google's Gemini,
previously called Bard, was falling far
behind. However, after 3 years of
catching up to open AI, Google might
have just gained the lead. And this is
because of their two AI models that they
released this week. And these two AI
models are the most visual AI models in
the world. The first one announced this
week, Gemini 3 is great with coding,
visualizations, and design. The second
one announced was Nano Banana, which can
create high quality infographics on
complex topics in one shot and a lot
more. And if you're an aspiring content
creator or entrepreneur or marketer,
these two models are critical to
understand. And in this video, I'm going
to show you the easiest way to use both
of these new Google models so that you
can create highquality infographics.
landing pages, full-on web apps, and
even 3D simulations. If you like videos
like these, please subscribe and hit
that like button. It helps me out a ton.
Anyway, let's dive into the video. Okay,
so Gemini 3 was just announced and so
the CEO of Google said it is the best
model in the world for multimodal
understanding. I agree. And our most
powerful agentic vibe coding model yet.
That is true. Gemini 3 can bring any
idea to life quickly grasping context
and intent. So you can get what you need
with less prompting. And we're going to
talk about how to use this in a little
bit. But I first want to cover what it
is. So what is this new model? What are
people saying? What are people building?
And then we're going to get to how to
use it. We're actually going to talk
about three places where you can use
Gemini 3 in this video. But first, what
is it? So Gemini 3 is the most
intelligent model that Google's ever
created, and it helps you bring any idea
to life. For example, Proirano, [snorts]
forgive me if I pronounce his last name
incorrectly, he oneshotted, apparently
he oneshotted a Lego set, like basically
this virtual builder where you can
change all of the angles. You can select
from multiple types of Lego pieces. You
could place them on top of each other,
as you can see here, fully rotate around
this board. And apparently, Google
Gemini oneshotted it. We're going to
create something just like this in just
a second. This dude Sahil oneshotted
this globe simulator. And you can see
here, this looks like a globe. He's
manipulating it, moving it around. It's
updating the time. And this new Gemini
model is very good at design. And it's
really good at creating things like this
with 3D models kind of embedded into it.
And even Samman thought it was a great
model. He said, "Congrats to Google on
Gemini 3. Looks like a great model." And
look at this. some good old
sportsmanship in the comment section
here. That's always fun to see. This
right here, this video really shook me
because it made me realize that we're
headed into a a new era of education in
terms of AI where AI is going to be able
to use coding, specifically little game
engines like 3JS to create these 3D
renders that actually help us learn how
to use AI. And so this is a really cool
explanation of a nuclear power plant.
And it shows you in stages and it zooms
in on the relevant part in this 3D model
as you click next stage. And this just
got my mind flowing with all kinds of
ideas here. Someone said in 3JS, which
we'll talk about and use in just a
second, create a Minecraft style snowy
winter nighttime Christmas house, pure
procedural. And here they're using
Google AI Studio or Gemini AI Studio,
and we'll get to that in a second. But
here it is snowing. It looks like
Minecraft, and it is this world that you
can kind of immerse yourself in. And I
think we're going to enter this era of
like really immersive landing pages.
These are so easy to create, why not
make a really fun and immersive landing
page as well as other educational uses
of this. So in summary, Gemini 3 is a
really good AI model like ChateBT or
Claude except people are saying that
this one is more visual. It has a deep
multimodal understanding and it's really
good at creating code that makes visual
outputs and people are building cool
visual stuff. They're creating video
games, simulations, and 3D learning and
a lot more. And so the question then
becomes how to use it. And so the first
way to use it and the easiest way to use
it probably is AI Studio. It's not my
favorite way to use it, but it is the
easiest I believe. You just type in AI
Studio in your browser. It's the first
link that pops up. You're going to sign
in. And as you can see here, you can
just you're using Gemini 3 Pro Preview.
In Google AI Studio, you have to go to
start and then you have to put it here.
We're going to build this. Okay. Yeah.
Now, this kind of opens up a lovable
style IDE here in the web. And now it's
going to begin building our app. And
here we go. It is done. As you can see
here, we can place Legos. I didn't
really put a detailed prompt, but this
is what you can do just on Google AI
Studio. Here we're Look, it can go up as
you can see here. Go down, up, up. Boom.
Can we get it in that little spot right
there? Oh, we can see that's pretty fun.
Then we can ask for changes. Please
allow me to change the type of brick.
Please make it such that I can make 4x4,
4x1,
etc. and more. And we can send that off
to Gemini 3 Pro Preview. There you go.
It literally just created this 2x one
shape that I can use right here. We can
stack them on top of each other three by
one. We can change the color to blue. We
can stack them on top of each other.
This is actually wild. I can't yet
rotate. Oh, I can rotate. Oh my god.
Here we have green shape. We can go 4x4.
How does this work? Colors green. Oh,
does 4x4 not work? What about 2 by two?
Okay, what's going on here? Oh. Oh, it
was updating. There we go. Colors green.
Does green just not work? Okay. No, it
works. This is one example of something
you can do. You could just get a
screenshot, a massive screenshot, and we
can save this to clipboard. Now, again,
you go to Google AI Studio, click on the
first link. Now, we're here. I'm going
to paste that screenshot. Make this
landing page exactly as is in this
screenshot and generate an asset to put
in the background with nano banana,
which we'll get to later. Please make it
look like the photo and exactly like it.
Boom. And so normally in a previous
world of vibe coding, you would actually
have to go to a new site, a different
site, generate the right image and then
place it in the project files and then
tell the AI to put it in the right
place. But here we're just telling AI to
look at this image that we gave it. This
image right here and it's going to
ideally generate a background image for
us. And there we go. It is done. And as
you can see here, am I able to full
screen this? Yes, full screen. So,
here's Superpower, my version.
Superpower.com.
Here it is. And they're somewhat close.
Somewhat close. And it even chose a
font. You know, it's somewhat similar
font. It has the exact same copy. And
look at that. And so, it used Nano
Banana to generate an image. Obviously,
it wasn't perfect, but it generated an
image of the background and placed it in
the background. And you can change
styles. It's really good at a bunch of
different styles. One thing that I
created with Gemini over the past uh I
think I created this two days ago is
copytheme.com. I made this in one prompt
where I just asked AI to generate a
bunch of mobile app devices with a bunch
of different themes so that I could just
quickly like copy themes. So this is
glass morphism. I can now hit copy and
now we can go back to Gemini, get it out
of full screen and say please change it
to this style now. And I can just paste
in that style. It's called glass
morphism. The modern frosted glass
aesthetic uses light translucent layers
with background blur and subtle white
borders to create depth and airess. Very
cool. So we are hitting rate limits
right now I believe on Gemini. And so
you just have to try again. I think that
there's so many people trying to use
Gemini that not all requests are going
through. So we are hitting rate limits.
If you try this soon after watching this
video, you may hit some rate limits. I
know it's happening on cursor as well.
So be wary of that. And there you go. It
just changed it. It got rid of the
background and changed it to the style
that we selected. And this is pretty
cool. And this is not bad. I mean, we
can full screen this. Um, you know, you
can't scroll, but I didn't tell it to
add anything beneath it. So, this is a
landing page created on AI Studio with
Gemini 3. The next place where you can
use Gemini 3, and my favorite place to
use Gemini 3 is in Cursor. cursor allows
you to use Gemini 3. And I will make a
very long video on this, but I will go
over this really quick. I can show you
that if we were to rightclick on cursor
and we hit new window and we can
actually open up a project and we can
call this new folder Gemini testing. Now
use create a folder anywhere. And what
we can do is we can now open up this
side panel. And here we go. We have
Gemini 3 Pro over here on the side. What
I can do is I can say create a 3JS
simulation of the water cycle. Make it
detailed and awesome and really
educational. And I want to be able to
press an arrow button to be taken to the
next stage. Really focus on making this
educational and taking me through the
full process. think deeply and really
make this an interactive experience. So
now we just type this into cursor and
now we let Gemini 3 Pro within cursor go
to work. Now we'll wait for it to be
finished. Something just opened up
automatically. I don't believe it's
done. Yes, it's still working. But this
just popped up on my screen. I can press
this arrow. This is looking pretty
interesting so far. Okay, so it's done.
And here we can go to localhost 8080.
Oh, what is this water cycle? Let's see.
Bang. Oh, evaporation. The sun heats up
and water in oceans and lakes. The water
turns into water vapor and rises into
the air. This process is called
evaporation. Notice the steam rising
from the water surface and the sun glows
brighter. Wow. Okay, let's go to the
next one. Condensation. Water vapor
rises into the atmosphere. It cools
down. The vapor turns back into tiny
liquid droplets. Okay. Precipitation.
That's pretty solid. Collection. Water
falls from the clouds, collects in
rivers and ocean. Some of it soaks into
the groundwater. Eventually, it flows
back into the ocean and the cycle starts
over again. That is really cool. And
that is just one example. Can you make
it more realistic
and just better? Really focus and make
it detailed and better. Go your hardest.
This should be the best thing ever or
you're fired. Let's see how it does. So,
it is done. Oh,
what? Look at the light reflections
here. This is kind of a weird body of
water, but you can see the evaporation
here. We have condensation,
precipitation,
rain flows over the land. Wow. I don't
know what's going on with the ground
here, but look at how realistic the
water is. That's pretty insane. Okay, so
that is just a very brief little
overview of cursor. Just a couple of
prompts to show you how easy it is to
use Gemini 3. The final one that I
wanted to talk about in terms of how to
use Gemini 3 is within Gemini. So
instead of typing in Gemini Studio, type
in gemini.google.com.
And here we're going to turn off that
right now. We can actually say, please
explain to me how to use Gemini 3 in
Google AI Studio. And what I want to
show you here is this model is also
really smart in a lot of different ways.
And you can use it directly within uh
Google Gemini which is their version of
chat GBT and it will respond to me in
paragraphs. And one thing that you can
do is you can actually turn on canvas
and you can say please write a more
condensed version of this and it will
take a moment and it will write this
out. And as you can see here when you
turn on canvas it actually writes it in
this like side view right here. we can
ask for things and then it will write it
in the side view right here and then
when you hit share you can hit export to
docs and this will actually export
whatever's in the canvas directly to
Google Docs and then you can immediately
share it with your team which I find to
be incredibly useful because I use
Google Docs for almost everything and as
I talked about in a previous video you
can also use Gemini in slides right you
can use Gemini in slides and now you can
also use nano banana which brings me to
the next section of the video which is
Nano Banana. Nano Banana was just
released and this one I actually haven't
been able to use for that long because
it just came out this morning and it is
so good at infographics. Let me show
you. For instance, what I could do is I
can actually take a screenshot of this
really lowlevel graphic right here. I'm
just going to copy it to my clipboard.
Now I'm going to go to Google AI Studio
once again. And when we go to Google AI
Studio, we are going to go to our
homepage, playground. We're going to go
to Google AI Studio, then playground,
and then we're going to make sure that
we are using Nano Banana, Nano Banana
Pro. And I'm going to paste that in
there. I acknowledge. Now, what I'm
going to do, please make this into a
high quality graphic that shows the new
nano banana capabilities AI image model.
Please add visuals beneath the text. You
see the Google logo should be the Google
logo and the banana image should be
actually an image of a banana. This
should be on graph paper and in blue
ink. And we can run it. Now we can run
that here. And now we're using nano
banana. And you can even think it even
literally thinks. So this is like a
thinking model that will generate an
image which is so cool the fact that AI
images have come this far. It's
absolutely insane. Look at this. This is
what it created. So it is Google logo
and it it it put it on graph paper. It
put this little line around it and it
creates infographics. This was just
something I wanted to try real quick.
I'm actually going to try a new one
except I'm going to do this within Crea.
So, Crea AI, and this is not sponsored
by Crea at all. I just really like to
use their app because it's super easy to
just use Nano Banana Pro. And I can just
go like this. I can change the dimension
really easily. I can say really high
quality graphic explaining the creator
relationship between a brand and
sponsorship and the benefits to both
sides, the the creator and the brand
sponsoring the creator. I want this to
be a very elegant infographic in thick,
no in blue ink that has a very light
graph paper in the background. Almost
like an architectural sketch, but it
should accurately depict the topic at
hand. Let's just try it. And what's fun
about Korea is you don't actually have
to like wait for it to like do all of
its thinking. You can just generate a
ton of these at a time. I believe you
can generate uh like 10 images at a
time. And in just a second, I'm going to
show you how to put these in a workflow
beginning to come in here. And look at
this. Look at these images, right? The
creator brand sponsorship architecture.
Create content, authentic voice, mutual
exchange, synergy, partnership, building
lasting connections and shared
prosperity. Brand benefits. And you can
see brand sponsor, creator benefits,
monetization, sustainable income,
audience, audience expansion with new
reach, professional resources, and tool
support. This is actually a genuinely
useful image. And all of these are very
interesting and I really think that like
tools like Gamma, which is an AI slide
deck creator, they're going to be
implementing these images directly
inside their tools and I believe Google
Slides is going to integrate it as well.
Of course, you can generate funny images
here. Elon Musk jumping over a river.
We'll do Steve Jobs. Apparently, it does
people. Like, you can do like, let's see
if we can do Spongebob
jumping over a river. They usually allow
you to do this on the first day to get
as many people as you can to use the
tool and then they'll stop allowing you
to do it because of copyright issues.
But here we can see Elon jumping over
the river. I actually don't think for
these hyperrealistic images. I think
maybe midjourney is a little bit better,
but the fact that you can create them
with famous characters is kind of fun
for now. But my favorite way to use
Google or Nano Banana, at least in the
past, is to use the edit feature within
Crea. So I can just drag this image in
here. And now I can just make changes
like make his shoes black and put a bear
in the background. And we can change it
to four. And here we have Nano Banana
Pro Edit 2. Generate. And there you go.
We see this bear in the background. And
we have four different variations. This
one, it's the closest. I like this one.
And then if you just click on this one,
you can continue editing this one. You
can say make the man wearing orange
pants. And you can just go for as long
as you want here using the new nano
banana model. And you can see them
coming in. Look at that. Now we have
some orange pants here. Very very cool.
Look at that. But before we move on to
the next section, I do want to show you
nodes. So this is also in Korea. You can
also do this in tools like Flora, Super
Studio by Kyber. There's a lot of
different tools that have this nodebased
tool. I just like to use Crea because I
already have a subscription. So the next
thing I want to talk about is Crea
Nodes. And this allows you to create
workflows using Nano Banana. And so what
I can do is I can hit N and this will
allow me to create like a text input
field. And so here what I want to do for
this is I just want to say take the
following concept and turn it into a
high quality graphic. And we can use
that same style that we were using
earlier. Make the background a very a
slightly off-white graph paper and make
all of the ink in blue almost like an
architectural design. explaining the
topic in full. And what I want you to do
is make sure that there's way more
images than text and make sure that
there's a good amount of spacing in
between topics and always show the
relations between topics. So if that's
the style that I want to use, I'm just
going to change this to style. And now
what we're going to do is I'm going to
create I'm going to press N. We're going
to create a text box right here. And I'm
going to call this one this one's going
to be called topic. And so let's say I
am writing a post or I'm I want to
create a graphic for a newsletter,
right? I just can put the topic whatever
I'm talking about in here. And so for
example, so I recently just wrote this
really short newsletter and I really
want to just copy this whole thing.
Actually, I want a good graphic for the
first half. And so I can just copy this
and we can just paste it into the Korea
nodes. This is about when the AI bubble
bursts. My argument is that more people
are going to be using AI. And what I
want to be able to do is just paste
whatever my topic is and then have an
infographic in this exact style. And
what I can do here is I can actually
create a workflow. And so here we're
actually going to create a new node. And
this is going to be called we're going
to use concat. And concat text all that
does is it literally allows you to like
put this text above this text. And so
this will just be combined. So, these
two texts will just be combined. And I'm
just going to say take the above concept
and I'm going to separate them so the AI
knows they're separated. And we're going
to drag this right in here. So, the
final output of this will be text one
plus text 2. So, all I need to do is
paste in my topic. And then I'll take
the output here and we will paste this
into Nano Banana Pro. And this should
generate an image. And we can actually
choose the aspect ratio 16x9. And then
what we can do is we can just copy and
paste them. Copy paste. So now it's
going to generate three, four. And it
can get kind of crowded. And so yeah, I
I think they definitely need to work on
like making these less crowded. But
let's say I want to have six options
because why not? And so this full
workflow will run. And now we're
generating these images. And you could
even use an AI intermediate step if I
wanted to to actually to come up with a
better prompt because you can actually
use LLM. You can use an LLM call, but I
actually don't know if we'll need it
because this model uses an LLM or it
uses it's a reasoning model within the
image model. And so we can actually see
these. And so you can actually just
download all of these. But I believe you
can see all of the generated images
here. And so now we have this. Look at
this. This is so good. This one, this
one, this one, this one, and this one.
And what's crazy is you could even if
you wanted to drag these out and you
could actually go to VO 3.1 and you
could actually turn this animated
infographic
video. And so we could actually have
this run in the workflow. So this is
actually going to animate this image
right here. So this image right here
will be animated using VO3.1 which is
the best video model in the world. So
now I can just download this video. The
AI bubble bursts overlays.
>> That is actually crazy. I forgot it
generates sound. I thought it would just
be a nice little animation. I haven't
optimized this yet. Today was the first
day that I've used this. But I will
definitely be using this for my content,
especially with graphics that pop up on
the screen, especially in short form
because visuals are so good for short
form content. And so anyway, this is
kind of what we've covered, right? AI
studio for Gemini 3, you can use cursor,
you can use Gemini, you can also use AI
Studio for Nano Banana, you can also use
Korea. And we talked about creating
workflows with Nanobanana with Korea
nodes. And the final thing I want to
talk about is creating AI rappers,
right? A lot of people have made money
creating applications, AI rappers, uh,
that use this technology. And the best
place to create mobile rappers using
this technology is with the Vibe Code
app. So, all I have to do is when
creating my mobile app on my phone, I
can go to the APIs tab. And you'll
notice in the text generation, you have
Gemini 3 Pro that you can immediately
add to the prompt. By the way, this
prompt is literally clawed code. And so,
I just can add it to the prompt. And
then I can also go to API and press
image generation. And I can click nano
banana and click that. And you can very
easily just say these are the models
that I want to use to do x y or z. And
then you can just send them to claude
code and it will do that. And you can
just send it to the AI and it will
create it. And then you can also use
image generation. You can generate
assets and put them directly in your
app. And this is how you can create AI
rappers that use this technology. And
I'll be talking about this a lot. You
know how much I love vibe coding if
you've been following my videos. And I
believe there's going to be a lot of
people who make a ton of money creating
rappers. And you can also use cursor to
create a web application or a desktop
application or you can use the vibe code
app to create mobile apps. And so that
is kind of an overview was a massive day
for Gemini 3. I'm really excited to see
what OpenAI and Enthropic launch as a
response to these models, but we'll wait
and see. Anyway, thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you here for the
next